- Why couldn't we get enough masks?
Why couldn't we get enough ventilators?
Why weren't there the perception
that there weren't enough hospital beds?
How come the morgues couldn't keep up?
And so on and so on.
How come we couldn't be prepared for this?
And no matter how you
look at it, at every area,
there was a failure of government.
(upbeat music)
- I'm Dave Rubin, and this is
The Rubin Report reminder everybody,
lockdown is more fun with friends
and ad-free video and podcasts,
so please consider joining
us at rubinreport.com
and joining me today is
the editorial director
at the American Institute
for Economic Research,
Jeffrey Tucker, welcome
back to The Rubin Report.
- It's good to be here, Dave.
Nice to see you again.
- Good to see you again.
I'm sorry we're not doing this in person,
but we are social distancing
like everybody else,
so, I guess my first question to you is,
well, just how ya doing?
How ya doing in a time of
social distancing and lockdown?
- (laughing) Well, I got to give
the same answer anybody would,
which is I can't believe that
this is the world we live in.
I never would have imagined
this even three weeks ago
but somehow we're fairing.
We're not starving, we're not dying,
we're talking to people, and you know,
I wrote a book called,
"The Market Loves You,"
and all I can say is the market,
although bludgeoned and truncated
and it's never been
attacked like this before
maybe in the history of the world.
It's still somehow working,
so I'm very, very grateful for that.
- Yeah, that seems like
the right start to this
because throughout the last month or so,
you're one of the few people I would say
that is making some
consistent sense to me,
at least on Twitter.
I think you're a pretty great
classical liberal thinker,
which is why I wanted to have you here
because I want to talk about stimulus
and I want to talk about markets
and I want to talk about the
Constitution and free speech
and right to assembly
and all of those things
that I know you and I
and my audience all love,
so, why don't we start with this,
which is just going off
what you just said there.
We seem to be more resilient
perhaps than we thought.
I mean, I think if you
would had said to people
six months ago, "hey, do you
know that in March and April,
"you're gonna be shut
down, locked in your house
"along with virtually
the rest of the world
"for now going on five weeks,
"and it could be months after that."
I think people would've thought,
"oh, there's gonna be violence,
"oh, there's gonna be looting,
"there's gonna be crime,"
all of these things,
and yet as you started
us with, we're doing okay
and the markets actually
haven't completely tanked,
we're going up and down, but
everything is kinda working.
- Oh Dave, I could tell
you such inspiring stories.
I just want to cry when I think about it.
You know, when I go to the grocery store,
which is one of the things you can do now.
It's access to real life and I go in there
and I first of all make sure to thank
every single worker
there for all of their,
that they're doing but I
like to talk to the managers
about how they decide what
they're going to do that day.
You know, was there a
run on chicken yesterday?
What'd you do about that?
Was there a run on sausage?
What'd you do about the salads
over here in the deli section?
How are you getting toilet paper?
How are you rationing it
given that there's restrictions
on price movements?
How has this changed your lives?
And all I hear are stories
of heroism and brilliance
and it's not just individual brilliance,
it's institutional brilliance
and it's the brilliance
of the market economy.
It's still working despite everything,
despite being clobbered in
ways that were unimaginable
just a few months ago,
and if I can say so, Dave,
this brings to mind a real paradox,
the times we're living through right now.
This shut down has presumed
the adaptability of society.
The capacity of society
to make this radical turn,
to go from one life to the
other life practically overnight
to adopt a seemingly impossible pose
and yet the government
edicts that have come down
have presumed the impossibility of society
to adapt to the presence of
pandemic disease, you know?
Like we can adapt to a complete--
- Is that adaptability?
Do you think that adaptability
is unique to capitalism
because of the way it
allows so many people
to be in the market and innovate and move
as things need to be moved?
- Yeah, it's embedded in the
essence of a free society
where people learn to be intelligent
and learn to control their world,
learn to cooperate with people
and create these market
signals that tell us in prices,
and interest, and all these things.
I think at the end of this,
if you're not a libertarian
you're not paying attention
because the market has
worked and brilliantly
and it's only not worked
when it's been hobbled,
and it has been hobbled.
It was hobbled before
this crisis actually.
We can talk about all the specific ways
in which that's true.
I blame, I don't, again,
I don't blame coronavirus
for your suffering right now.
Viruses have always been
with us and always will be,
and society had developed
ways to deal with this virus,
and medical professionals especially
have learned how to deal with a virus,
and it's a challenge for any
society under any conditions
but what you want above all else
is freedom and adaptability,
and to decentralize decision-making
and then you ask, Dave, for some reason,
we took a completely different direction.
Fortunately we haven't
shut down the stock market,
we haven't shut down essential stores
and it's thanks to that
we're eating today,
that we're sleeping today,
that we're able to get by,
so it's not the government that we owe
the fact that we're
surviving through this.
It's 100% the element of freedom
that remains in the system.
- But Jeffrey, I keep
reading all these brilliant
think pieces saying how
this shows the failure
of libertarianism and limited government
because this, if ever, this is the moment
we need big government to do things
and the very people who have
been calling Trump Hitler
for four years, are now
demanding that he do more
with his power, am I not
understanding things properly?
What am I missing here?
- (laughing) I tell you
what, I think you and I
share the same frustration.
The response of the left
has been alarming to me
to the extent that I find indescribable
because I think last
time I was on your show,
I myself was warning about the danger
of the authoritarianism of
Trump and we can get to that.
- Yeah, yeah.
- I think he's made
some bad decisions here and
they stem from his experiences--
- Let's explore all of it, for sure.
- Yeah and the extent
from his own nationalism
and his own illiberalism, really,
which I think it's seriously problematic
but my God, day after
day to see these howling,
oppressed people all have
decided that the narrative
is that Trump is some
sort of Bastiat figure
who's just not doing anything
and that people are dying because of him.
It's a real shock and I don't
wanna say I'm grateful for him
because I think he's made his errors
but for day-to-day I'm
sure you feel the same way,
my God if the Trump
administration went along
with what CNN, MSNBC and
the, I'm sorry to say,
unspeakable "New York Times",
"New York Times", a venue
that I've always adored
and always read and always loved.
- Yeah, yeah.
- And to see what they did,
what they helped enable,
I just don't know.
If there's any such thing
as moral culpability,
I think, I'm so sorry to say
it, again it breaks my heart,
I think the "New York
Times" is morally culpable
for what's happened to this country today
and I listen to "The Daily" podcast
and I saw the hysteria being ramped up
and the demands for crackdowns
and the call for a
medieval response to this
and the demands for, I don't
know what you would call it
but a fascist, communist
social distancing policies
and it's been grim and shocking
and you've been shocked,
I've been shocked, I
don't know what to say.
- So it's so interesting
that you're as concerned
about the media element as I am
because it seems to me
that we're fighting two viruses right now.
We all know about the
coronavirus and how to fight that
but the misinformation
virus that is now permeating
throughout the media and
it's "New York Times"
and it's Vox and it's CNN
and the list goes on and on.
It's making it almost
impossible for any of us
to have what I would say
is a sane conversation
because we're all dealing
with different sets of information.
How concerned generally
are you about that?
- Tremendously!
I actually, I summarized this,
you know we've all been talking to friends
and what's happened and things
but I memorized it the other day
that I really blame hucksters, scientists,
fake scientists comforted
by the howling media,
anti-Trump media combined with
a panicked political class
and it was a kind of a perfect storm.
Those three elements cam
together and lead to a level
of wreckage that's
unspeakable and unconventional
morally and I have to tell you
because for years people have told me
about the evil of the mainstream media
and I've never really wanted to go there.
I'm a big believer in press freedom
and I never wanted to
be one of those people
to trash "The New York Times"
and actually I love "The New
York Times", I always have
but I feel like I've gotten
a real wake up call here,
a real shock.
I don't know how you can be
in the mainstream press today
and be salivating over
the clicks and the views
and the amount of ad buys that
you're generating from this
while watching freedom
just go down the drain.
It's been a shock to me, I
just can't even describe to you
how horrifying it's been to
me and to tell you the truth,
I've really turned it off, I've had to.
- Yeah, I think, well we know
that people are turning it off
in tremendous numbers and
watching things like this instead,
so as a liberty-minded
person, as you said,
if people don't come out
of this more libertarian,
something will have gone wrong,
what are the proper approaches
for a liberty-minded government?
So, say a libertarian or
classic liberal set of ideas
that could get us through
something like this,
what should we have done at the beginning,
what should we have done as
we're going through it right now
and what should we be
looking at for the future
if you want to keep
people as free as possible
while also dealing with something
that we've never dealt with before.
- Dave, if I were gonna summarize
my position in a sentence,
it would be something like this,
the medical professionals
in the medical industry,
free of all restrictions
should have been allowed
to deal with this virus
from the very beginning
without the intervention
of politicians, period.
I mean, that I think is the end.
- So basically, just get rid of red tape,
just let them do their thing,
no more regulations on
experimental treatments,
that kind of stuff?
- Yeah and not only that but
if you think about it, Dave,
a lot of this flatten the curve analysis
that lead to the crackdowns
and the mandatory social distancing
and the universal house imprisonment
that we're dealing with right now
was due to the perception
that the medical industry
was unscalable in the event of emergency.
Now that's very interesting,
people need to be asked
the question, if it's true,
why was an industry unable to scale?
Industry is specialized in scaling,
when people buy more of your product,
as an industry you're
excited to offer more
of that product or service to them,
what makes the medical industry
unique in that respect?
Why couldn't we get enough masks?
Why couldn't we get enough ventilators?
Why weren't there, the perception
that there weren't enough hospital beds?
How come the morgues couldn't keep up?
And so on and so on,
how come we couldn't be prepared for this?
And no matter how you look at it,
at every area was a failure of government.
It was that the system
was heavily regulated,
the strategic medical reserve
disincentivized hospitals
from gathering their own supplies.
The tariffs on masks
seriously inhibited them
and this is very personal to me
because I have friends in New York
who are nurses and doctors
who were sharing masks
and they can't get enough
and the tariffs seriously hindered that
and the hospitals didn't
have enough supplies on-hand,
'cause they assumed that it was all there,
that federal government
was putting it all together
but then of course they
opened the warehouse
and the half ventilators don't work.
The supplies weren't there
'cause they'd previously been depleted.
Every area, all you see is
government irrationality,
the inability of hospitals to scale,
the panic of the political class
to force everybody into their homes,
which is definitely
where you should not be,
whether you have respiratory disease,
the answer is to get outside
as everybody understands.
You don't wanna put old
people with young people
'cause that causes endless
amounts of infections.
You actually wanna isolate
and separate the people
who are vulnerable to this disease,
which are the old and frail
and last thing you wanna
do is close the schools,
'cause COVID, as we know
know, is actually not fatal
for young, healthy people, so
at every single area, Dave,
the government has done the wrong thing
and I don't know how long or
how detailed we wanna get here
but the testing fiasco was
the great, I would say,
beginning of all of this stuff
because China had already gone through
a trail run of this stuff.
We had this benefit of
this, we saw this coming
and the CDC and the FDA stopped,
and this is a matter of record,
really stopped private researchers
from developing the test
and distributing the test
from the very beginning
of this crisis, so that
was a catastrophic thing
and that lead to what
I've called, pardon me,
an epistemic crises, we didn't know.
We didn't know who had
it, whether I had it,
whether you had it, what
we should do about it
and how it was transmitted,
who was vulnerable to the fatalities,
what the case fatality rate
is, we didn't know anything!
So we replaced knowledge
that we could have used
with power and panic
and here we are today.
- So is one of the inherent problems,
that we have fighting the bad ideas
that would encroach on our rights,
that even if you lay out to people,
well here's all the things
that government has done wrong
all the way and here's why
it can never work properly,
that they always say,
"well that just means
"we need more government, that
just means we need to give it
"more money so it can be bigger,
"so that we can put more studies out there
"to make sure it knows
how to do these things",
and that answer always sort
of sounds easy and right
for people that aren't really thinking.
It's much harder to say to people,
"oh, the government actually
should've been scaled
"way back on this, so we could
have let the professionals
"deal with it,"
that sorta sounds scary to people,
especially at a time
right now where we feel
like the future is just
up in the air right now.
- Yeah and I think this speaks
to a little bit of something,
a principle that's animated
your career in your life,
which, you had a passion some years ago,
a realization that people
don't appreciated freedom.
They don't have confidence in freedom,
that freedom was being
attacked fundamentally
and philosophically by both
the left and on the right too
and I think you worried about that,
you actually asked yourself
a very important question,
what happens in the event of a crisis
where we need freedom more than ever?
And yet, we don't have the
intellectual foundations in place
where there's not a cultural love
of this thing we call freedom
or much less an understanding
of it, what happens then?
And I think that was a
very interesting perception
that you had several years ago,
that you really dedicated
yourself really hard
to this problem and tried your
best to do something about it
but I think what we're seeing right now
are the results of a
culture that's forgotten
the meaning of freedom
and what if you lose that,
what do you replace it with?
You replace it with the police
state, with poor planning,
with chaos, yeah.
- Yeah, something not good,
so right now as we sit here
all trapped in our houses,
trying to figure out what to do,
how concerned are you about
some of those basic freedoms
that we're talking about?
I mean, right now the right
to assembly, for example,
we cannot assemble together,
you can not get 10 people
in a room to do anything.
We had our bizarre mayor, I'm being nice,
de Blasio in New York City,
say that if he found temples
or churches that were
having any gatherings,
they could be permanently closed.
Now again, I'm all for the
six foot social distancing
if that's what the
professionals are telling us
but the idea that we could
permanently close these things
and we can't assemble or
our right to free speech
in that we know that even right now,
big tech is removing blog posts
that run counter knowledge.
That's not necessarily
the government stepping in
and doing it but if we look
at some of our key freedoms,
assembly and speech being
the two at the moment,
how concerned are you
that we're just gonna sort of
put them aside throughout this
and then it'll be six
months later and we'll go,
"oh, we had those things?"
- Yeah, I think anything is
possible right now, Dave,
and anybody who says otherwise
hasn't been paying attention
over the past couple of
weeks, there's no chance,
so I looked before we met up just now,
I looked back at what
I wrote January 27th,
'cause I wrote an article
warning that the quarantine power
could be used and explained
why this is a very, very bad idea
but even in that article, I
imagined something like this
that the government would
set up quarantine areas,
which in fact they have them,
and they would come knocking on your door
and grab people out of it,
maybe one family at a time
and put them in the quarantine area
or they would target maybe neighborhoods
and round everybody up
and put in paddy wagons
and put 'em in the quarantine area
but even January 27th, I never imagined
that governments of the
world would put everybody
under what amounts to house arrest,
so the face that this has happened,
I would say at this point,
anything's possible.
I worried 'cause we put
out a book last week
called "Coronavirus and Economic Crisis",
a book put out by American
Institute for Economic Research
and I put it on Amazon
and I gotta tell you,
I was worried, I was worried
that Amazon would take it down,
so I printed separately
lots of copies independently
with an independent publisher
and started making it
available on the website,
just in case we face massive censorship.
I actually, if I were
going to describe it,
I would say we're that close, that close
and once you get rid of, and
it's very interesting to me
that you use this word right,
you've been using this
repeated a right to assemble,
a right to associate, a right to speak.
A right is not something
that's contention,
it's something that you actually possess.
It's not granted to you by the government,
it's something you own by
virtue of your humanity.
It's hard to talk about
rights in these times
and we don't, apparently, have
the right to our own property
'cause the government can
shut down our business
on grounds that it's unessential, right?
We apparently don't have the
right even to leave our homes,
so once you take that away, I mean Dave,
I don't wanna be an alarmist
about this or anything
but look, from a philosophical
or intellectual point of view,
we are living the practical reality
of what comes very close to being
a totalitarian state right now.
Now fortunately, thank
you political leaders,
you're letting the grocery stores work,
fortunately they're private.
Thank you for letting us have pharmacies,
they're private entities too,
so we're grateful for the
little bit of private markets
that are left but the
attack on everybody else
and the attack on our rights is shocking
and the social consequences of
this are unspeakable, really.
People are not gonna comply,
they're not complying now.
I'm sure you know this,
in fact you've probably attended them
but there are speakeasies
and all over New York City, popping up
where you can go to dinner
and gather in more than five,
more than 10, even 30
people and they're drinking,
they're having dinner together,
they are in defiance of the law.
Friends of mine in Manhattan
sit in their penthouses
and every night after
nightfall people rush out
into the streets with noise makers
just to illustrate that
they believe in freedom
and for God's sake, do we not
believe in freedom anymore?
The politicians presume
that we're like pieces on a chess board
that can just move around
but you know what?
That's not true, that
is not the human mind.
We are not inanimate objects,
we are not birds in cages,
we will live free, one way or the other.
- But so what would you say?
So of course I'm with you
but what would you say
to the people who would say,
"but all of those people, your
friends that are going out
"onto the streets at night and
the people that are getting
"together at speakeasies and going out
"more than they have to
go out and the rest of it
"and exercising their rights and freedom,
"that those are the people
that are gonna keep this thing
"spreading because people
don't know when to rein in
"their own personal responsibility
"and do something so that
society doesn't crumble",
something like that.
- Well at the height end
of the enlightenment,
where we discovered this
idea of human freedom,
there was also disease (chuckling).
We didn't have very clean water,
there were annual viruses that
came along and killed people
and there were pandemics and so on
but they still, somehow, came to believe
that human beings have the right to speak
and associate and trade
and we work around it
and part of the belief in freedom,
is the confidence that
society has the intelligence
to deal with things like
viruses that come along
and the existence of
disease does not disable
the whole of modernity, it just doesn't,
we can't think this way!
Modernity with forged at a
time when there were diseases
and even back to the Black Death in Venice
in the 13th century when there
was still very dangerous,
they still kept trade going.
There was some towns would
come up with the restrictions
and that sort of thing
but the idea of violating people's rights,
fundamental rights to
live and choose and speak
and everything was even
unthinkable 500 years ago.
The odd response we've done here
is premodern, it's medieval,
it's 11th and 12th century style stuff
except with 21st century technology
and we're not responding to
these things scientifically
even the slightest bit.
The response by the political class
and I mean from about March 15th onwards,
was nothing short of
mystical, superstitious,
it was a panicked response.
Let's just throw everybody in
a cage of their own creation
and punish anybody for coming out of it
and I totally forgive people
who are going to these speakeasies,
you could say that they're prudent,
they shouldn't be doing
that but for God's sake,
people exercising that fundamental right,
I'd say we need more of that
not less of that right now.
- Do you think that's
partly just human nature
that so many people just
operate purely in fear,
so a month ago when we
had that two day window
where suddenly everything
shut down out of nowhere.
They announced the entire
NBA season was canceled
and then they canceled
all these public events
and everything sort of
happened within a two day thing
that there becomes this odd rush to cancel
because you don't wanna be the one guy
who's going against the crowd, right?
You don't wanna be the one guys who says,
"no, we're not gonna cancel our season,
"we're not gonna cancel all of our things,
"we're gonna wait it out a little bit,"
knowing that the risk you
take of being just destroyed
by the media and everything
else on the other side,
is probably worse than just
going along with the crowd,
with the wave.
- Yeah, I understand your point.
I have my doubts that there
was any public support for this
actually at all.
Now it's entirely up to private venues
whether or not they wanna
have these gathering
or accept the liability
associated with NBA games
or South by Southwest
and that sort of thing.
South by Southwest didn't
choose to cancel the conference,
that was a governmental decision,
so I'm looking at this and I'm
not saying whether that was,
maybe South by Southwest
should have canceled,
I don't know, I think about this a lot.
I'm not actually sure about that
'cause that's mostly
all young people there
who are actually not in any
great danger from COVID,
so I'm not sure about that
and it's hard to do factuals here
but with this much, Dave, I
know and I think you know too.
Politicians, by which I
mean governors, mayors,
senators and congressmen and so on,
are not owners of anything.
Their main job is to get
elected again, that's it,
so they don't really have a
financial, economic stake.
They don't have skin in the
game apart from the desire
to get voters to vote for them again
and there was a sudden panic
on the part of political
leaders at all levels, really,
that if anybody died
while they were in office,
that they would somehow
be blamed for this,
unless they just bludgeoned people
and ruined people's lives,
so they somehow believe
there's less risk to
steal people's property
and arrest people in their homes
than it was to be blamed
for a public death
and that gets us back to a problem
that began this discussion,
the role of the media here.
'Cause what they're really
fearing, ultimately,
is this cancel culture, the Twitter mobs
and "The New York Times" editorial page
and the media culture
that's lost all rationality and clarity.
They're afraid of being denounced
and dragged through the mud
and drowned and quartered
and so on by the press,
so I ultimately, it
really does come down--
- Wouldn't that feel like
a perfect storm to you?
- Yeah and--
- Doesn't that feel
like a perfect storm
of the end of the media
that we've all been seeing
and as you said before,
you didn't even want to see it
but that so many of us have seen
the end of mainstream media,
we've watched our academic
and political institutions crumble
and then something like this comes in
and just takes the last
remaining foundation of it
and then adds fear to it
and you take fearful people
who don't even understand
what their rights are
as you alluded to earlier.
- Right.
- And then you really
have the perfect storm
to control everybody.
- I like this phrase, the perfect storm,
and I think it's the best
description to explain
what's happened to us, really.
It wasn't really a conspiracy from the top
but of course, you know
there's conspiracy theories,
so we'll never stop them.
They've been generated by the day
and I totally forgive that,
people wanna understand
what's happened to their freedoms,
what's happened to their rights,
why did the world go dark suddenly?
And people assume there
was some central plan
but I don't believe that actually,
I think it was just this
combination of factors.
- Yeah.
- And I've been wanting
to write about this for a while but yeah,
it is a perfect storm
it was a howling media,
panicked politicians
and just this onslaught,
combined with a lack of information,
what I've described as an academic crisis
that led to a complete panic
but we're gonna be
spending the next 10 years
trying to figure this out,
exactly how did this happen?
Let me just draw attention
to one thing Dave,
and I'm not sure you're
really with me on this
"New York Times" that I'm a
part of, probably you're not,
you left it long ago but
I have been listening
to "New York Times'" "The
Daily" for a long time
and I'm an admirer, I'm
friends with Michael Barbaro
and I like, I think these
reporters are fantastic
and I want this to be a good paper
but I'm not sure whether once I've--
- Of course, I want it to be too.
- Yeah, yeah, let's--
- Yeah, well let me
just be really clear on
that, I want it to be.
Every time, even in the last few days
where I've had to go after
"New York Times" people,
just in the last few days,
they did a piece on misinformation
in the age of corona
and they included my name in a chart
about a tweet that went viral
and then I tweeted about
it, I tweeted about it
and I didn't even tag the author,
I had never even heard of him before
but then he tweets back at me
and says that I wasn't even
mentioned in the article,
even though my name was in the chart
in the middle of the article,
he said that doesn't count as a mention
and it's like, you guys
with all your double speak
and nonsense, my name is in
the chart in the article.
I want them to be good, I
don't like it when people
come up to me on the street and say,
"Dave, you're one of
the few people I trust,"
I go, "oh man, we're in a lot of trouble,"
you know what I mean?
They just have to be
a little less horrible
but they seemingly can't do it,
so I'm with you on that,
although maybe I never thought
they were as wonderful as you did.
- It's been heartbreaking
for me because I think,
and I have to look back at the days here,
'cause everything's a fog, you know?
It's a fog of corona as they say
but I think it might have been early March
when "The New York Times"
"The Daily" podcast,
which is listened to by
millions and millions of people.
I mean, it's beautiful podcast,
beautifully produced, fantastic venue.
They have on this reporter,
a disease reporter
and he comes on the air and
begins to raise public panic.
Now there was no panic in those days
and you'd think "The
New York Times" would be
like a responsible, and usually
they're trying to diminish
the panic, they're trying
to calm everybody down,
that's usually the ethos.
This was the opposite, he was going,
"we're all going to die, oh my God,
"we better carry Purell
with you everywhere
"and spray every single
surface with hydrogen peroxide
"and if we wanna get rid of this,
"we're all going to have to drop in place,
"wherever you happen to be
and live there for two months
"or else this is gonna wipe
out the whole of humanity",
this is a guy who was saying this stuff
and he has this authoritative voice
and he's very compelling and everything.
I listened about the third
podcast with this guy,
now you get three times to
take over a what so amounts
to a 25 minute show,
three times in two weeks,
you better be good but I
looked up the guy's background.
Is he an epidemiologist?
No, was he trained in medicine?
No, does he know anything about viruses?
No, he, Dave, this gentleman
has a degree in rhetoric
from Berkeley University.
A degree in--
- I was gonna
guess creative writing,
rhetoric is even better.
- Yeah, so--
- Yeah.
- And he's 66-years-old,
so I'm thinking about this,
what is his expertise?
He's got a great voice for radio
and he's some sort of totalitarian,
I don't know what else to say
but they gave this guy this,
basically what amounts
to an hour and a half
over the course of two weeks
to spout of totalitarian blather and BS
to their audience of millions--
- Well how much of that do you think
is just that "The New
York Times" in this case,
'cause that's who we
happen to be talking about
but we can talk about it
within a broader media lens,
is that they've invested so much time
in a Russia collusion hoax,
they've invested so much time
in impeachment and all of
these things that did not work
that in many ways, as Bill
Maher said about a year ago,
he would be all for the economy tanking
if that's what it takes to take out Trump,
that they now see a little
blood in the water here
and they go, "oh, if we have
to destroy the entire country
"to make sure this guy
doesn't win in November,
"we'll kinda do it because
we got nothing left."
I mean, this is the one,
it's one we couldn't have thought of
and it's the one that they have left.
- Well I'm stunned that
you brought up this idea
and I have to admit
that it hasn't been
entirely out of my mind,
I have actually considered this too.
It's such a perverse
thought, I think we'd need
Sigmund Freud himself to
take care of this one.
- [Dave] Yeah!
- But the timing is very interesting.
We had the Russia thing
then we had the Ukraine impeachment thing.
- Yeah, yeah.
- We have
the daily fanaticism that apparently,
the tireless fanaticism, I
don't know what else to call it,
to every single day run 18 articles
accusing Trump of ghastly pathology
and anybody who supports
him as being just vermin
who needs to be exterminated
and that's been the ethos
for "The New York Times"
with very few exceptions,
there are a few exceptions
but that's been the ethos,
so I wonder sometimes
too if that explains,
maybe that doesn't explain
everything that's happened to us
but it explains this strange lust--
- Yeah, a lot, yeah.
- That we had
in the early days, yeah.
This burning passion,
like irrational desire
to bring the economy down,
to accuse Trump of something,
to, you know like in Batman,
'some people just wanna
see the world burn",
you know that line?
- I love that line from "The Joker",
that's Heath Ledger's Joker, yeah.
- Yeah, yeah, so look
I've thought of this too
and it's a extremely disturbing thought
because well let's just
say, if they imagine
that this was just gonna be
a political thing to take down Trump.
What they've done is they've
dismantled civilization,
however temporarily,
itself and I don't think
anybody could have imagined this
and I've not talked to
Michael about this since then,
I hope, I would love to meet up with him
because I think he's a
dear man and very charming
but I wonder if even he is startled
about what he's unleashed and by the way,
I'm not sure that Michael
himself is responsible
for who his guests are,
you know what I mean?
You pick your guests
but you have full control of the program,
Michael's just the host of the program,
so I'm not sure Michael
bares any moral culpability
for what happened at "The New York Times"
but I wonder what he even think--
- Right, so I don't listen to the podcast
but it's sort of like,
if you think about it,
it's a "New York Times"
podcast, we hate Trump,
we've tried to get Trump every other way,
why not bring on someone
that, as you said,
is not a medical expert or anything else,
but a rhetorical language expert.
Let's make everyone
crazy because that fits
everything else we're doing,
but I wanted to jump to
something that you said before,
'cause I think this is
very interesting, you said,
"I don't like dealing in counterfactuals,"
and I think one part of this
is how hindsight is 20/20
and everyone pretends
to be an expert today,
when they were ignoring
things way back when,
so I checked and there was
no mention of coronavirus
at any of the Democratic debates
until the last one that they had
which was only Bernie and
Biden alone on March 25th
and that's when coronavirus was brought up
and there was no audience
and everything else.
They had debates on February 7th,
February 19th and February 25th.
Now we've got the media running around
and all the Democratic
politicians Pelosi and Schumer
and everybody running around saying,
"Trump should'a done something
in January, we all knew it,
"blah, blah, blah", it
not only didn't come up
in any of their debates,
but he did try for a China
travel ban in January.
What do you make of that part of this?
That we just sort of look
at the people in charge
and we pick randomly who and
when they should've done this
or that knowing that nobody
else did anything either.
It didn't come up once,
why didn't it come up in
the debate on February 19th?
The one right before
the February 25th one,
if everyone was talking about it
you'd think six days before,
nothing, strange huh?
- Yeah but the looks of that
as a great scoop actually Dave,
I'd never even thought of that before.
I wrote my first article on
this topic, January 27th,
I could have written about anything else
but I was watching what
was going on in China,
I knew that quarantines might be coming,
so I decided to lean in
and I discussed this in great detail.
Actually in January 27th,
the idea of this wouldn't
even be brought up,
two weeks later, two
and a half weeks later,
three weeks later and
the Democratic debate
is actually, that's extremely telling
and yet everybody looks
back at Trump and says,
"oh look, you're an idiot,
"you didn't prepare
properly for this," so yeah,
so they had this hindsight thing,
which is fine, we're
not omniscient figures.
We don't know what's going-
we're all, Ross Douthat
about this beautiful article
again in "The New York Times"
today, so they run good stuff.
Beautiful article about
how few people there are
are experts about this at
all but you would think
that early on, that they
would have consulted-
that's what bothers me most about this
and then it just drives
me crazy, actually,
that once they realize the
coronavirus was a thing,
why weren't they calling
epidemiologists and experts
and medical professionals and
people with specializations
in dealing pandemic diseases
and asking what they think?
Why weren't they calling John Honiotes
or Knut Wittkowski from
Rockefeller University
or why didn't they pay any attention
to the 800 medical
professionals, epidemiologists
and biostatisticians that signed a letter
put up by Yale University
begging our nations leaders
and political people to
not shut down the economy,
to not pursue this locked-in strategy.
Why wasn't the press
even slightly interested
in the fact that 800 medical professions
associated with Yale University
wrote a public letter begging
America's political leaders
to not do exactly what they did.
Where has been the press throughout this?
Why has it been you, "Reason" magazine,
American Institute for Economic Research
and just a handful of other venues
that have been left to report
what medical professionals
are saying, can you imagine?
I think about a guy like
Knut Wittkowski okay,
so it's like 35 years
of researching viruses,
their transmission, the
policy response to them,
how they work, what you should do.
This is a serious guy, one of the heads
of the Human Genome Project,
this is his life and he lives in New York
and this whole world
unfolds before his eyes
and that whole world's
collapsing around him.
His phone didn't ring,
he didn't get a single
email, nobody asked him
and finally you're just desperate
and shocked and horrified.
How do you spend your life as
a professional in this area
and then when the critical
moment in your life comes along
where civilization could
use your expertise,
everyone completely ignores you
and you're just some dude siting alone
and you have to wait for
an independent filmmaker
to come along and do
an interview with you.
Same thing happened John Honiotes
who had an article in
2005 about fake science
that took over the world,
he was like a media star.
He's exposed fake science his whole life,
he's a specialist in biostatistics
and he had a lot to say about this stuff.
Nobody asked him, we destroyed the world
without ever consulting the
actual medical professionals
about this, not "The New
York Times", nobody cared
about the actual
specialists in these fields
who were pleading and begging
and trying to find somebody to talk to
and get their message out to
the point that Yale University
actually had to distribute
this open letter
from 800 medical professionals
which was subsequently completely ignored
by the mainstream press.
It's a disgrace, we're gonna
be dealing with this for years
and I think that there's
gonna be hell to pay
on the part of the mainstream
press for what they've done,
what they've done to the world,
the missed opportunities,
the morally egregious abuse
of their power over the
public mind in the last month,
it sickens me more than anything
else I've seen in my life
and I like a free press, I
believe in press freedom,
I believe in all these things.
I think it can and does
work but this is an abuse,
to cheer on the end of our
rights and liberties like this
and so cavalierly and if you're right,
as you are just asking the questions
and I'm asking the questions too,
was this all driven by a
pathological hatred of Trump?
Is this it, is that what drove it all?
I don't know but if that's true,
somebody needs to be held accountable.
- You know it's so
interesting listening to you
because there is this sort of undercurrent
of you're a non-alarmist
when it comes to COVID itself
and you're trying to figure
out how we can be free
and actually, in the last five minutes
what really animates your
fear factor, your fear senses
is everything else related to it
and I think that is where
a lot of people are at
where we're at least
confused as to the real depth
of the fear we should have
related to the virus itself
and most people are trying their best
to do the best they can and not go outside
and the rest of it but that's
not really where the fear is.
I actually think that the fear
is what you're talking about right now,
that it seems like every
sense-making machine
that we've had is no longer functioning
or is trying to manipulate
us, we're seeing through it
in a very clear way and
that is freaking scary
and especially for people
who maybe not my audience,
that's seen this for a while
or the younger internet audience
but if you're a boomer,
not to pile on the boomers all the time
but if you're the type of person
that really isn't that
checked-in to this stuff
but now you're really starting to see it
and you're seeing that
the future of your life,
your retirement, savings,
all of these things
are gonna change drastically.
The world that you thought
existed doesn't exist anymore,
that's, I think, much scarier
than actually getting sick at the moment.
That's a real flip
that you wouldn't hear
on mainstream media.
- No but you're exactly right
and I knew that this was true
from, I would say probably,
the first week of March
that the most terrifying
thing was not the virus.
You know we deal with annual
new flu strains every year
and we have for 150,000 years actually.
We have medical professionals
who deal with this.
We have therapies, we
have ways to deal with it
and then we have tests, we have vaccines,
we have herd immunity strategies,
we know what we're doing
in dealing with disease
but when it comes to
dealing with a totalitarian
state apparatus that's taken
away your rights and liberties
as cheered on by a howling,
deeply ignorant media apparatus,
that's what's really scary.
I was writing this morning, Dave,
if I could just quickly
tell you about this
and I'm sure we all have our own stories.
- [Dave] Yeah please.
- But I have an accountant here
at the American Institute
for Economic Research
who's hounding me for
my receipts from March
and I'm busy, I couldn't get
to it until this morning, busy
but then you know what it's like
to go through your receipts,
you've been through that,
you've been there before,
so now the receipts,
Dave, from March first,
so I got to see every Amtrak I took,
every restaurant I ate at,
the hotels I stayed at,
the taxi cabs I took, various things,
glassware I bought for
the house and so on,
so I had to relive this
month through my receipts
and it was horrifying,
I'd really had a sense
that this is the old world
and this is the new world
but one day I seized on was March 12th
because I was in the city
going to a television interview
and I was there with
my friend Taleed Brown
and the city was starting to
panic, it was very interesting
and we got there about
10:30 and my interview
wasn't really 'till four so I
had about four hours to kill,
so I went to my favorite
Irish pub and we sat down
and there were, instead of open tables,
there was suddenly paper
on the tablecloths.
This is a time when people
knew that something was coming
but they didn't know what it was.
They knew for sure by this
point that there was a virus
and probably it was in New York
but that's not what was really in the air.
What was in the air was
the fear of the response.
We can deal with viruses,
don't sneeze on me,
don't cough on me, maybe
set my phone down over there
I'll pick it up, we can deal with that.
Okay, I caught the virus,
gosh I'm gonna be down a
couple of days and so on,
we can deal with that but the idea
of suddenly having the Amtrak close?
We didn't know what was gonna happen
if the streets shut down, the
cops arresting people in bars,
we didn't know what was gonna happen
and Taleed and I sat there
between 10:30 and 11,
I tell you Dave, what was
very interesting that,
I have to write about
this, but bars were packed.
They were packed not because
people thought life was normal
but they just were certain
that life was about
to become really unnormal
and they were drinking.
They were just gathered around
and drinking themselves silly.
I said to the person who's
waiting on us, I said,
"have you ever seen this
kind of drinking at 11AM?"
She goes, "I've been here five years,
"I've never seen anything like this",
people just drinking
themselves silly out of fear
not of the virus so much.
- Yeah, of the other thing.
- But of the public panic
and the political response
and those hours that went by
between 11 and four when I
finally did my interview,
were terrifying 'cause I just didn't know
if we could even get the next train out
and after the interview,
we rushed to Penn Station
just as fast as we could and
when we got on that Amtrak,
we were both just
breathing a sigh of relief
and even then I wasn't sure
if the train was gonna move,
so when it started moving
and I looked at Taleed
and I said, "I know it's a two hour trip
"but when that train stops at Hudson,
"that's when my heart
is gonna stop racing,
"'cause this is terrifying," yeah.
- Yeah and there's so
many versions of this.
One of the things that I've
been thinking about personally
is my grandmother-in-law is 85,
lives alone in New Jersey,
none of her children
or grandchildren live in New Jersey,
so we've been having food delivered to her
and I have a friend that
lives about 30 miles away
who's dropped off some stuff but the idea
that what if the states close
their borders, you know?
What if you can't get food to somebody?
All of these things that
we thought these things
would never be possible
in an American contest,
the fact that all of us right now
are eating home all the time
and just hoping that Amazon
can keep delivering things.
I actually, it's a weird thing
because the silver lining is,
I think maybe we did need
a shock to our system
to understand really what is freedom
and what is being independent
and not so reliant on the system,
so I am enthused about that
but I'm also worried that a lot of people
haven't ever thought about it before
and that now they're gonna
suddenly think about it
and then who knows which way they'll go
because they might just
put their hands up and say,
"no, just help me government,
please do everything for me,
"I'm just completely
incapable of doing anything."
- I wonder what the
response is going to be
and I think that's partly
your job and partly at my job
in the days and weeks and months coming,
if ideas matter at all, getting
out the message of freedom
and liberty and prosperity and
safety through those things
is, I can't imagine more important
work than that right now.
It's going to require voices like yours
to get that message out there
to help people understand
and make sense of what's happened
because philosophy doesn't
just come automatically,
people need to be able
to hear a body of ideas
and connect it with your own experience
and if we do this right, we
can make a difference I believe
because the reality is all around us
but it needs interpretation
to understand it.
It needs a body of thought to connect it
and we're all struggling
with that messaging,
I mean my messaging is
why didn't they leave it
to the medical industry
and to society itself to handle
instead of having the
politicians take over
because it's the politicians
and the regulators that
have ruined the world.
They've took a bad thing, which is a virus
but actually not the first
virus and not the last one,
and turned it into a
calamity for civilization,
that's not a good thing and I
hope that coming out of this,
we're gonna put massive
restrictions on the political class.
I don't mean just
constitutionally you look at
'cause it's framed on your wall,
I mean something that's really binding,
that makes something like this impossible,
so the court system actually works
if a mayor tries to lock
you in your home again,
the courts will say, "no!"
And then suddenly he's out of power,
that's the kind of system we need.
We need massive deregulation
in the medical world
and in the labor markets
and ever area, the--
- You mean you don't
think it's a great idea
that my mayor here, Eric
Garcetti here in Los Angeles,
is asking us to snitch on our neighbors
if they're doing something
they're not supposed to do
and we might get a reward for it,
you think that's a problem?
My dog Clyde and I, we've
been out taking walks
and we're hunting down people,
'cause we're trying to get
some of that reward money,
is that a problem?
- (laughing) You know, I
hope that people reflect
on basic humane values going forward here
like decency towards
each other and freedom
and that that inner moral
sense that we all have
will prevail over our desire
to destroy each other.
(Jeffrey laughing)
I really do hope so.
- Jeffrey, I think that's the
right way to end an interview.
You truly are one of the clear sane voices
and I think it's really shining right now,
so I'm thrilled that
I can help amplify you
at a time like this and
just stay safe and sane
and I look forward to
actually doing this in studio
hopefully in the not too distant future
and then we'll go to a
bar at 11AM and get wasted
and commiserate over
the rights that we lost,
how does that sound?
- (laughing) That sounds great Dave
and it's wonderful to
count you as a friend.
We all need each other right now,
both friendship but also
philosophical allies.
Let's go forward here
with moral conviction
and intellectual integrity
and ignore everything else around us
and just do what we know is right
and I think that's the best that we have.
- And that is how you end an interview.
If you're looking for more honest
and thoughtful
conversations about politics
instead of non-stop yelling,
check out our politics playlist
and if you wanna watch full interviews
on a variety of topics, watch
our full episode playlist,
all right over here and to get
notified of all future videos
be sure to subscribe and
click the notification bell.